the history of ancient rome tells of an
empire so mighty it defined forms of
government architecture and civil
engineering that exist to this day but
as mighty as it was rome still wound up
falling apart historians and scholars
have tried answering why for centuries
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives four
experts cover the events that led to the
fall of rome and they highlight how the
eastern roman empire persevered for
another thousand years afterwards we
begin now with a quick look at some
popular perceptions of the fall of the
roman empire enjoy
in the 5th century a.d
an unstoppable tide of uncivilized
savage barbarians pour across the
borders and the tottering roman empire
is simply overwhelmed beneath hordes of
these ferocious brutes
in the popular imagination and in many
movies
this is the dominant image of the end of
the roman empire
almost every aspect of this admittedly
powerful vision is problematic however
and the reality is considerably more
nuanced
by the beginning of the fifth century
the roman empire had overextended itself
in the words of historian barbara
rosenwine at the height of its power the
roman empire wrapped itself around the
mediterranean like a scarf
and the empire included much of what we
think of today as western europe the
middle east and north africa
in the first century rome had even made
it all the way to britain which it
wanted to control because of its natural
resources like tin
once in britain rome did what it did
everywhere it went it made a little roam
its citizens lived in villas they went
to public baths there was a coliseum
here a stadium there an impressive
network of roads so people in military
units could get about quickly there was
taxation
bureaucracy and once the emperor
constantine had converted to
christianity in 313 there were churches
and monasteries as well
now i'm oversimplifying a lot here but
it's basically the case that those
people living in the central part of
britain in the year 400 were what we
would call romanized britons this means
a large portion of the native population
that was mostly originally culturally
celtic so they're the ancestors of
people we think of today as the irish
the welsh the scots
these people over time had come to think
of themselves as romans with all the
rights and privileges of any citizen of
the empire
rome's decline has begun nearly two
centuries earlier
around the year 235 ce the emperor
severus alexander was murdered in a
mutiny led by one of his army commanders
from this moment forward the empire
becomes increasingly unstable
invading tribes of goths visigoths huns
and vandals move into the power vacuum
fighting one another and threatening the
imperial authorities
still it's important to understand that
the goths and romans have never been
implacable enemies they've had close
links since the middle of the third
century particularly in
trade in the half century from
235 to 284
the roman senate will ratify no fewer
than 25 emperors
and that's not counting the several
pretenders who create fiefdoms and lay
claim to the imperial purple
the romans who live in the capital
become increasingly anxious to protect
themselves from the barbarian hordes
that are sweeping into italy from the
north
the able emperor diocletian restored
some semblance of order late in the
third century dividing what had become
an ungovernable empire into eastern and
western halves each with its own
leadership
then civil war erupted and constantine
fought his way to power
constantine claimed to have had a vision
the night before the crucial battle of
the milvian bridge in which he saw
himself raising a cross as his symbol
his success in the battle encouraged him
to decree in the year 313 of the common
era that christianity would henceforth
be tolerated throughout the empire
12 years later in 325 he invited all of
the leading christian thinkers to
assemble at the council of nicaea which
resolved critical disputes over
christian beliefs
in 330 constantine made the old greek
city of byzantium the capital of the
eastern empire and it was later renamed
constantinople
but the endgame of roman civilization at
least in its classic form was fast
approaching
various german tribes have been
increasingly drawn into the power vacuum
created by the crisis of the 3rd century
the roman army recruited many germans
into its ranks and allowed others to
cross the borders and settle on roman
land although many of these communities
were mistreated by corrupt roman
officials
german restlessness was exacerbated by
the arrival of the militarized huns from
central asia
in keeping with the popular perception
this was indeed a period when the
peoples commonly referred to as
barbarians invaded
or some would say
migrated into the roman empire in
hitherto unprecedented numbers
there were also new bands of barbarians
who appeared on the scene and posed a
greater threat to rome than it had
previously experienced
who were these barbarians the term
barbarian was originally a greek one
simply meaning
those who could not speak greek
but it eventually became a pejorative
label
used by the greeks and romans to denote
almost any group that they regarded as
less civilized than themselves
during the republic and early empire the
nations labeled as barbarians who fought
against rome in gaul germany spain
britain and the balkans were not one
unified society or civilization
but were instead dozens of separate
tribes
each with its own specific culture
traditions language and religious
practices
during the early empire clashes and
sometimes full-scale wars against
innumerable barbarian nations along the
rhine and danube frontiers had been a
constant preoccupation
these conflicts had included great
victories for rome but there had been
major disasters as well
nevertheless the existence of the empire
itself
had rarely if ever been threatened
and no hostile barbarian had set foot in
the city of rome for eight centuries
it's important to understand that the
barbarians are not intent on destroying
the empire
rather they want accommodation within it
not infrequently barbarian tribes and
leaders would be recruited by one
faction or another
given roman titles and privileges and
then employed in civil wars
there was also a growing tendency for
the eastern and western halves of the
empire to
turn inwards and focus on their own
problems failing to cooperate when
common threats appeared and refusing to
support one another
all of this was complicated even further
by continued external pressure from
barbarian tribes on the frontiers
and economic crises within the empire
in the early 400s one of the most
important barbarian warlords who became
enmeshed in roman politics was a
visigoth named alaric
at various points in his career he had
served in the roman army fought on
theodosius's side against arbogast at
the battle of the frigates river
turned against the romans and looted a
number of major cities
been bought off by the romans with huge
cash bribes been appointed the general
in charge of all roman forces in the
lyricum
fought with steliko invaded italy and
threatened to attack rome
been bought off yet again with money and
titles again threatened to invade and
then actually block hated rome
finally in 4 10 a.d alaric and a band of
visigoths marched down into italy
captured rome
and for three days
looted the capital
although the damage to the city was not
severe and alaric and the visigoths soon
departed with their plunder the
psychological effect of this blow was
immense
for the first time in over 800 years a
foreign enemy had occupied the
traditional capital of the empire
the city of rome was
invested with profound symbolic
significance for the romans
and their failure to protect it made
plain the reduced state of roman power
as nothing else could have
the sack of rome plainly advertised just
how weak the empire or at least the
western half of it had become
a message that other barbarian tribes
would be quick to take note of
as a result of this the result of this
sacking
rome called all the legions back to the
center of the empire
now
take a second and imagine
what would happen if almost overnight
all your peacekeeping and your military
personnel disappeared and a population
used to comfort and order
and dare i say civilized living found
itself with no security infrastructure
whatsoever
those left behind were farmers crafts
people
members of religious orders in other
words they were people who were
completely unprepared for what happened
next
and what happened next is that the picks
from scotland and the scots from ireland
and all kinds of germanic groups from
the continent recognize that hey
britain is ripe for raiding
and raid it
they did
among those attacking groups were
raiders from tribes that hailed from
non-romanized northern europe and this
is the region that the romans had often
referred to as
germania these groups were culturally
similar to what we tend to think of when
we think of our sort of stereotypical
viking
they were pagan
warlike they were excellent seafaring
peoples and they worshipped gods similar
to those in the norse pantheon like odin
they included groups
like the angles the saxons the jutes the
phrygians danes swedes
norse and a whole bunch of others that
it would take too long to go into here
germans now settled all over western
europe the visigoths in spain the
burgundians in the rhone valley the
francs widely across gaul and the angles
saxons and jutes in britain
the huns meanwhile led by the
charismatic attila were finally defeated
by a combined roman and visigoth army
near toy and their confederation
completely disintegrated after attila
died of a hemorrhage in 453 on the night
of his marriage to a german princess
europe was saved
without his leadership the huns
splintered into small groups and would
never again pose as serious a
threat the western empire was on its
last legs however
in 455 a.d the vandals under their
warlike king geyseric sailed up the
tiber river and captured rome
sacking it much more thoroughly and
destructively than alaric had done
earlier that century
still the western empire continued to
limp along
and there was still officially a roman
emperor even if he no longer ruled over
much
various barbarian warlords and the mold
of steliko continued to exercise great
influence within roman politics and over
the emperors
in the period between 455 and 476 a.d
the most powerful of these was a
visigoth named risimer who was the
grandson of the visigothic king walia
a new phase was initiated in the mid
470s when the notional western emperor
was a young man
with the rather
pretentious name of
romulus augustulus
recalling both rome's original founder
romulus and its second founder the first
emperor augustus
now he was a
completely undistinguished ruler and
probably would be utterly forgotten by
history
except that in 476
he was deposed by yet another barbarian
serving in the roman army
this officer
named odo acker
then
broke with precedent by declining to
install a new puppet emperor
but instead simply declared himself
the king of italy
this act gave romulus augustolus the
dubious distinction of being the last
official roman emperor in the west
from now on barbarian kings would
control the territories which had once
constituted the western half of the
roman empire
by the end of the 5th century a.d the
western roman empire centered on rome
had fallen
or at the very least had been
transformed into something that was no
longer truly fully roman
on the other side of the mediterranean
the eastern roman empire with its
capital at constantinople most certainly
did not fall
and would continue to flourish for
another 1 000 years
although they viewed themselves as
simply the romans later historians have
labeled this empire the byzantine empire
after the original name of the old greek
colony byzantium located at the site
where constantinople would later be
built
today the same city has undergone yet
one more name change and is now istanbul
in turkey
the city of constantinople founded in
330 at the site of the old greek city of
byzantium by the roman emperor
constantine the first increased in power
and opulence under his successes until
it rivaled rome itself and surpassed all
other cities of the eastern
mediterranean
the city's status was further enhanced
by the decision of the orthodox
ecumenical council of constantinople to
make that city's bishop the patriarch
second in precedence only to the pope in
rome
of the approximately
95 emperors who ruled over
constantinople
the most significant of the earlier ones
was a man named justinian
his rise to power began as a boy when
his uncle justin became emperor and took
on his nephew as an assistant
justinian quickly became his uncle's
main confidant and advisor
and when his uncle became senile took
over de facto administration of the
empire
upon his uncle's death in 527
justinian succeeded him and embarked on
an energetic program of building
organization and conquest
spectacular rebuilding of the city's
defenses and of the great church of
hagia sophia further enhanced
constantinople status as the greatest
city of western afro-eurasia
the city lost some of its splendor in
the 7th and 8th centuries following a
series of natural disasters and
desperate sieges but in the 9th century
a military and economic recovery took
place leading to the great cultural
achievements of the middle byzantine
period and the city's reputation as a
place protected by military and
commercial strength and by god
an unbroken succession of roman emperors
ruled over this eastern or byzantine
empire
all the way up until 1453
when constantinople at last fell to the
ottoman turks
it might seem odd to us today to speak
of a roman empire
that does not include rome or italy
but the byzantines certainly regarded
themselves as real romans and pretty
much everyone at the time thought so as
well
if one accepts the eastern empire and
its rulers as being romans
a legitimate argument can therefore be
made that the roman empire did not fall
until 1453
and indeed this is the date that is
favored by many historians
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here